you you obviously  learn it so much from nip man is there  anything like on the entrepreneurial  side you're getting involved in because  you know he's  kind of laid the blueprint for a lot of  the this generation you know what i'm  saying  what to do when it comes to just you  know  having a bunch of eggs in different  baskets  besides the music [ __ ] for sure yeah i i  say  the biggest thing you know i'm saying  that i want to  continue you know what i'm saying per se  from nip is just the community you know  i'm saying like different outlets  outside of music you know what i'm  saying just to  promote growth and wellness  just within ourselves bro just all  generations i feel like  it's necessary for someone you know i'm  saying able  to step in and kind of play that role  fire